- Okay, so you're known for being just,
like for people that don't even know you,
we just assume that you're like
this super suave James Bond guy.
And I know my family does
not think I'm cool at all.
Do your sons think you're really cool,
they think you're suave or they just like,
he's our dad and he's dorky?
- Oh, I think they think I'm dorky.
I think I'm getting dorkier as I get older
and get into my later
years, my winter years,
you begin to kind of just,
really begin to show who you are.
I think they think I'm cool.
Yes, my son Paris calls me a
legend, "You're a legend dad."
- Aww.
- He's very, he's 19, he's 19,
- Well, and they're following
in your footsteps I bet.
They're all, they love the
entertainment industry,
the film industry, that's cool.
That's a sign of being so inspired by you.
- I hope so.
I hope, I mean Keely, their
mother is a great inspiration
and she keeps the whole boat afloat.
Without her, we'd be rudderless.
So, she has kept the feet
to the coals academically
and consequently they have
a really good education
and good hearts and
they've got a good head
on their shoulders and
they've seen dad and mom
go through the rigors of
quote unquote show business.
- Yeah.
- Which is, it's a tough game,
it's psychological warfare out there,
it can really just pull
you asunder if you're not,
you don't have your feet on the ground.
- And if you don't surround
yourself with people
that help you do that.
Yeah.
- Exactly so.
- Yeah.
- But they're good lads,
they're really good,
and then here, I mean,
life is very quiet here.
We're very fortunate, very blessed
to be in this part of the,
of the Earth right now.